pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de robe de bure pour le roi baudoin
au château a redonné de ciergnon le
souverain a présenté à la presse sa
fiancée dounia fabiola de mora y aragon
ici entre sa mère et la princesse de
réthy l'événement parfaitement inattendu
a donné un sérieux motif de réjouissance
au coeur des belges qui en manquait plus
tôt depuis quelques temps
les choeurs britanniques sont contents
depuis la publication de ces finales
familiale prise au château de balmoral
c'était en effet la première fois qu'il
leur était donnée de pouvoir admirer à
satiété le dernier né de la famille
royale
le petit prince andrew maintenant âgé de
sept mois
l'angleterre peut être satisfaite andrew
est un beau bébé
[Musique]
moins d'un mois après la décision du
sénégal de se séparer du soudan en
abandonnant la fédération du mali
monsieur mamadou dia président du
conseil sénégalais est venu informer à
paris le président de la communauté de
son intention de demander l'admission de
son pays à l'onu
dix jours plus tôt à dakar l'assemblée
sénégalaise avait sanctionné la
séparation du sénégal et du soudan elle
se donnait alors un président de la
république et accordait l'investiture à
monsieur mamadou dia nouveau chef du
gouvernement
dans les formes voulu par la nouvelle
constitution
[Musique]
autant d'événements qui s'opérait sans
heurts tandis que la vie continuait et
que le mouloud réunissait à tivaouane
l'habituel foule des fidèles avec les
présidents senghor et mamadou bien la
grande mosquée était ainsi devenu le
lieu où se réunissaient l'importante
confrérie musulmane tidjane dont le
souci majeur à cette époque de l'année
et la préparation du pèlerinage à la
neige car tel est chaque année le destin
de la petite bourgade qui équivalent one
elle devient du jour où l'on n'a une
cité de san millan pour retomber
aussitôt après dans le silence toute la
côte américaine de miami à new york a
maintenant subi l'assaut de l'ouragan
baptisé d'anna qui depuis le début
septembre se promène dans l'atlantique
une promenade à 200 kilomètres/heure aux
antilles et en floride
il a laissé derrière lui 139
daudelin cet acquis le triste privilège
d'être considéré comme l'ouragan le plus
destructeur de l'histoire américaine
[Musique]
villes satellites créé de toute pièce
autour de stockholm farce car on retient
l'attention pour une autre raison les
plans de son chauffage urbain lusine
chargé de chauffer l'eau des radiateurs
pour les 35000 habitants sera pour la
première fois une centrale nucléaire
souterraine et fonctionnant à l'uranium
initiative révolutionnaire qui n'est pas
resté dans le domaine des projets à
quatre kilomètres de farce cas dans les
entrailles d'une colline les ouvriers
s'affairent isolé par 20 mètres d'europe
lusine s'édifie dans une salle de 55
mètres de long 10 7 de large et 44,2 au
dernière conquête pacifique de l'atome
le chauffage urbain l'uranium a pris la
place qu'occupait jusqu'ici chardon et
mazout
en pleine poussée démographique la
france compte chaque année cinq cent
mille habitants de plus ce seront demain
de nouveaux consommateurs pour lesquels
de nouveaux moyens de production sont
nécessaires pour sa part la sidérurgie
qui en 1950 produisent et seulement 8
million et demi de tonnes d'acier ont
produit 10 est aujourd'hui et prévoit
d'en produire en 1965 22 à 23 millions
de tonnes pour suivre ce rythme des
terrains où naîtront des usines finances
sont gagnées sur la mer des hauts
fourneaux les plus grands jamais
construits en france continue de
s'édifier cathédrale des temps modernes
les ensembles sidérurgique produisent
toujours plus d'acier c'est à dire de
rails de poutrelles de file de tôle qui
vont au gré des trains et des péniches
alimenter les industries de
transformation
mais là n'est pas le seul objectif
l'assiette aussi une source de devises
grâce aux exportations réalisées chaque
année par la sidérurgie première
industrie exportatrice de notre pays
[Musique]
au congo les rebondissements se sont
succédé c'était d'abord la tentative de
monsieur lumumba de prendre possession
du poste d'émissions radiophoniques
plusieurs camions de trompeloup bis ont
voulu occuper radio léopoldville gardé
par les casques bleus qui leur en ont
refusé l'entrée le général une doula
passer du grade de sergent à celui de
chef de l'armée congolaise a discuté
longuement après deux longues heures de
suspense dramatique pendant lesquelles
les forces armées se sont fait face les
congolais se sont finalement retirés
[Musique]
sur ces entrefaites monsieur viléo le
nouveau chef de gouvernement nommé par
monsieur kasavubu faisait son apparition
en annonçant à la presse la formation de
son ministère de son côté le colonel
mobutu appuyées par l'armée annoncé
qu'il prenait le pouvoir et dénoncer
l'intervention de l'urss
brandissant une brochure soviétique orné
d'un portrait de croo de chauffe
il ordonnait en un temps la fermeture
des ambassades soviétique et
tchécoslovaques bientôt après on devait
voir le personnel de ces ambassades
préparer leur déménagement et brûler
leurs archives
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le délai de 48 heures fixées par le
colonel mobutu l'ambassadeur soviétique
monsieur yakovlev quitter son ambassade
et chesnay
[Musique]
et le pavillon soviétique était amené
est pliée avec beaucoup de soin dans
l'éventualité d'un usage prochain
[Musique]
a kyoto qui depuis les âges les plus
reculés demeure le centre religieux et
culturel de japon la calligraphie des
caractères est cultivé dans les écoles à
la fois comme une science est comme un
arbre
la leçon qu'on porte un cérémonial tout
en train de cette vieille civilité
japonaise qui a survécu à tous les
avatars et à tous les bouleversements
[Musique]
heureux enfants européens qui pour
remplir leurs pages d'écriture n'ont que
26 lettres à calligraphier les jeunes
les prêts japonais eux ont non seulement
six mille caractères à apprendre mais
ils doivent encore savoir les dessiner
[Musique]
anachronisme peut-être mais aussi et
séduction assez rare dans un monde qui
perdent beaucoup de son pittoresque
[Musique]